five National missions
Mission One Secured the highest
sustained growth in the G7 with good
jobs productivity growth in every part
of the country growth that makes
everyone not just a few better off
mission two
build an NHS fit for the future by
reforming Health and Care Services to
speed up treatment harness life sciences
and Technology reduce preventable
illnesses and cut Health inequalities
mission three
make Britain's Street safe by reforming
the police and Criminal Justice System
preventing crime early tackling violence
against women on girls and stopping
criminals getting away without
punishment
tough on crime tough on the causes of
crime now you've heard that before
but it's right
Mission four break down the barriers to
opportunity at every stage for every
child
by reforming Child Care reforming
education raising standards everywhere
and preparing young people for work and
for life
and five yes we will make Britain a
clean energy superpower
and these missions these five missions
will form the backbone of the labor
Manifesto the pillars of the next Labor
government
they will be measurable so we can track
progress and be held to account
long term so we can look beyond the
day-to-day
informed by experts in the public so we
can build a coalition for change
and each will support our drive for
growth each will help us get our future
back